Let's go get one of my pregnancy cravings. And lately,
my husband and I have been craving the exact same thing.
So when he said he wanted Korean barbecue,
I needed it right then and there.
So we went to one of our favorite spots.
My favorite things are the side dishes.
The pickled cucumber kimchi,
sweet potato noodles,
everything. So I started off by trying all the sides.
We got the all you can eat
because lucky eats for three people,
so that's the only thing that makes sense.
I also ordered this kimchi stew.
It was so good,
especially with the rice.
And the tofu was really good.
It was spicy,
but not too spicy.
And then we got five orders of beef bulgogi
and spicy pork belly.
Lucky always grills up the meat,
and he always make sure that I get the first batch.
There's nothing better than beef bulgogi
with fresh kimchi.
Lucky ended up ordering another three orders
of beef bulgogi and three more rice.
I clocked out at this point.
I made him try the kimchi soup.
He absolutely hated it.
But he also doesn't like kimchi and soup,
so I was kind of expecting this.
At this point,
I was stuffed,
so we left to get something sweet.
I always need something sweet after my meals,
and my favorite thing lately have been
vanilla cones from McDonald's.
I don't think they had talked about enough.